6 26 on your friday morning what's cool
at school well students who may have
been too young to understand the tragedy
of one october they are learning to
spread compassion at the southern
highlands prep school they're using art
to share their heart the head of the
school's pto says the kids there made 58
hearts each with a message of kindness
from something as simple as smile and
wave to your neighbor
to something profound and real like
brave heroes make las vegas strong
they're accomplishing their mission
the kids who made those hearts those are
the third graders from mrs smith's class
these are the kids from mr wassini's
second grade class southern highlands
prep a pre-k to eighth grade campus far
south valley they're actually letting
the kids stay home today for staff
development now if you know something
that's cool at school please let us know
head over to andrewsnow.com go to the
community tab look for cool at school
you can just send us an email to cool at
school at 8newsnow.com